قبل نحو ثلاث سنوات كان الشهيد اياد
الحلاق المصاب باضطراب التوحد يحاول
النجاه بروحه لكنه سقط برصاص جلود
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي رغم علمهم بحالته
الصحيه وفق عائلته انا
ربيت شابه بالصبر ربيته واجهت ما يغرقاش
صعوبات شديده جدا بتربيته
لتقبل المجتمع له ولتقبله للمجتمع
ويواجه الفلسطينيون المصابون بالتوحد
صعوبات في الوصول الى المؤسسات
الاسرائيليه المختصه والتواصل داخلها اما
وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه فلا تتوفر لديها
احصائيات دقيقه للمصابين بطيف التوحد مع
ندره المراكز والطواقم الطبيه ويقول مسؤول
الوزاره انهم يسعون الى تقديم خدمات وان
كانت محدوده احنا بنقدم خدمه وتوعيه
للوالدين بحيث يعتبر الوالدين هم
المعالجين المباشرين
للاطفال ما في عنا ما يكفي من مؤسسات التي
نستطيع الاعتماد عليها
كمؤسسات للتدخل الفعال مع الاطفال الذين
يعانون من توحد هنا في هذا المنزل برام
الله واجهت والدته التوامين كنان وكيان
تحديات قاهره بسبب نظره المجتمع لطفليها
لكنها كانت الاقوى في هذه المواجهه
المجتمع كثير ترسعد تبعنا كمان انه هو
كمان مش بس انه صعب يتقبل همش للاولاد وما
بحتويهم وما بخليهم يكونوا معهم يعني في
المجتمع في المدارس في الحدائق في اي مكان
لا هو كمان يعني باشياء تانيه حتى بحاول
يغسل الاهل انهم كانوا السبب مثلا مركز
وتكوين للعنايه الدماغيه والنفسيه للاطفال
في محافظه رام الله والبيره يستقبل اطفالا
مصابين بالتوحد ويسعى الى اعدادهم
للاندماج في مؤسسات المجتمع ولازم يكون
على راس اولويات الشركات الخاصه والعامه
بشكل لما يكبروا يوفروا لهم فرص عمل اللي
تتناسب مع مقدراتهم واهم شيء لازم يكون
على راس اولويات عيالهم واهلهم وصولها ذيل
الطفلين الى مقاعد الدراسه وهما من اصحاب
طيف التوحد يعكس نموذجا ناجحا لتخطي عقبات
المجتمع من جهه وتحدي الظروف الخاصه من
جهه اخرى وهو ما يفتح الباب على مصراعيه
امام فئات المجتمع لتحمل مسؤولياتها
وتقديم جميع اشكال الدعم لهذه الشريحه قبل
فوات الاوان سمير ابو شماله الجزيره رام
الله فلسطين